Democrats have swept back to power in
the US House of Representatives and they
immediately flex their new authority by
passing a new budget bill that snubs
president Trump's key demand for
billions in funding for a US Mexican
border wall the Democrats are presiding
over the most diverse house in US
history which for the first time
includes Muslim women selfies with
friends and supporters Rasheeda Tayyip
is one of the first to Muslim women
elected to Congress a historic moment
look forward to seeing all the great
things that she'll do and all of those
that she will represent and the voice
that she will provide to to those of us
that typically are overlooked
the congresswoman from Michigan still
has to learn her way around Capitol Hill
just like her fellow Democrat Diana
Presley from Massachusetts who brought
her family to celebrate the swearing-in
day with her I'm humbled and grateful
and many people have asked me if I'm up
for if I feel pressured either because
of these struggle significance of being
a first or because of the crossroads we
find ourselves at as a country or the
fact that we are coming into Congress in
the midst of a government shutdown and
to that I would just say that I don't
feel pressured I feel a tremendous
responsibility and I plan on doing
everything possible to meet that every
day the new Congress has already made
history by setting a record number of
women and becoming the most ethnically
diverse while the Republicans still have
more seats in the Senate the new
Democratic majority in the House of
Representatives is poised to serve as a
check on the US president their first
challenge is the governmental shutdown
the standoff between the Democrats and
Donald Trump could set the tone for a
combative two years and in these two
years it's this woman who will face off
against President Trump Nancy Pelosi
extend to you taking the gavel as a new
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi
reclaimed the post she already held from
2007 to 2011 nation is an historic
moment two months ago the American
people spoke and demanded a new dawn
they called upon the beauty of our
Constitution that our system of checks
and balances that protects our democracy
remembering that the legislative branch
is article 1 the first branch of
government co-equal to the presidency
and to the Judiciary
the new majority quickly went on the
offensive approving bills to reopen the
government but without the money for the
border world president Trump demands
with a conflict likely to intensify for
the newly elected lawmakers this is only
the beginning for more on this story I'm
joined by Boris Foreman he's professor
of politics at Bard College here in
Berlin specializing in American public
policy thank you for joining us this
morning
now the democrat-led House has approved
a new draft budget bill that does not
include funding for the border wall that
President Trump wants will that do
anything to end the standoff with
President Trump and and get people get
federal employees back to work well I
mean it's taking the position I think in
part this is symbolic politics this is
about taking a stance making clear to
Trump also that the next two years will
be more rocky terrain than it has been
in the first two years of United govern
government well I mean you're right this
basically bought saving face and Trump
is not gonna accept it the Senate is
probably not gonna pass it there's no
chance whatsoever for this to come
through but this is about symbols what
can we expect to change in Washington
with this new House of Representatives
well I think one thing that's certainly
going to happen is that the pressures on
Trump will increase even in united
government his legislative record is not
of his administration is not very strong
he has had the tax cuts and that's most
of what he's been able to show many of
the things that have happened in the
first two years were executive decisions
were ruled by decree and this is
something that doesn't have the
long-term sustainability so the things
that Trump has has implemented so far
would theoretically be easy to dismantle
if there were were democratic president
after his administration now so we're
going to see a
the attempts to use subpoena power to to
perhaps start an impeachment which
probably is going to fail as well
because the Senate isn't the hand of the
of the of the Republicans but there's
gonna be a harsh wind that goes against
Trump just one more question on this
budget impasse how do you see this
playing out
that the side seat seems so hard in
their positions yeah that's that's a
tough one I think many of the things
there might be some kind of a trade-off
a Mitch McConnell and others in the
Republican Party have been trying to to
launch attempts of having some kind of a
compromise to also offer something
something to Democrats in order for them
to support a bill that would also fund
the frontal wall but the positions are
very hard and it's a reflection of the
deep polarization in the political
system that has been around for three
decades at least so yes there is an
impasse okay we have an impasse in
Washington not too much new they're a
professor Boris Foreman at Berlin's Bard
College thank you so much for joining us
this morning